[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel
man does it feel good to be back i'm
greg ivory alongside the man the myth
the legend sam richmond
welcome back to the show sam how we
feeling about these games today
man i'm thrilled to be back
game tonight uh and playoffs are right
around the corner this is this is where
i thrive with futures and vp bats i love
it so i couldn't be more excited to be
here
playoffs are awry on the corner and sam
you do thrive
with those future bets but as always
we're giving away locks hoodies jerseys
and you know what i got some brand new
br betting basketball shorts i'm giving
away today
and i'm kind of jealous about that sam
because i don't even have any br betting
basketball shorts do you
you you got a pair bro
no no
sam needs one i need one the people need
one so let's get this party started get
in the comments everybody i need gifts
emojis but most importantly we need
winners only please in fact
i'm about to hop into these comments and
give away a jersey right now
i got snoopy
snoopy says
snoopy 2153 says ooh
it's sam today yes snoopy just for that
take just for that take just for you
identifying we have sam on today
you are walking away with a hoodie
actually a jersey you're walking away
with a jersey but yes everybody we do
have sam the sharp on today but it's tnt
thursday which means we are betting the
three by two sam the question is will
there be two three pointers in the first
three minutes
of the game we asked you on twitter
which three by two will cash tonight
brooklyn milwaukee utah taking on those
los angeles lakers and here are the
results
there they are and this one is a
landslide it looks like the audience is
taking the earlier slate in the
milwaukee brooklyn game uh i need you
guys to get in the comments and tell me
which three by two is a lot but sam
gotta start off with you brother
which one are you thinking which way are
you leaning
i how can you not ride with the people
here i mean look at the the firepower in
this game you've got kd kyrie seth curry
middleton i mean all the shooters are in
this game i can't trust the lakers to do
anything right now i will take the three
by two and buck's nets
sam's rocking with the three by two in
the milwaukee bucks
brooklyn next game so i guess that means
we might have to rock with it as well
but let me get into these comments first
let me get into these comments uh
i got i want to win says riding with the
squad ride today they're looking for the
same game parlay
shout out to you i want to win we will
get there you're walking away with a
hoodie uh i got kyle willy802 says nah
the bucks are winning tonight giannis is
dropping 50 tonight
shout out to you you are also walking
away with the hoodie
uh
d wise 44 says milwaukee brooklyn and
i'm gonna end right there shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you guys are
walking away with hoodie sam i'm gonna
put my foot down the comments were all
over the place i'm gonna put my foot
down and say we are riding as a family
we are riding the brooklyn nets
milwaukee bucks three by two tonight so
let's all get rich let's all ride as a
family and we need this one to cash
tonight sam but it's my favorite part of
the show let's talk major markets money
lines against the spreads and point
totals for tonight's game let's take a
look at the odds sam what are you seeing
here and what do you like
yeah you might notice kind of a theme
with my takes today so i apologize to
the city of los angeles to lakers fans
everywhere
but your team just isn't very good so i
know it's a lot of points i know it's 13
and a half
uh but i like the jazz tonight they've
lost like five in a row to me this just
screams like perfect bounce back spot
where they'll be locked in off a losing
streak against a team that is just not
very good so uh a lot of points but i i
think uh the jazz uh smoke the lakers
tonight so i'll i'll take the minus 13
and a half
sam
wow bro i am like
shocked you're taking all those points
but guess what guess what i'm i'm going
to do something unusual as well sam i'm
going to do something unusual as well
the point total for the brooklyn nets
milwaukee bucks game sitting at 243
that's really really high it's really
hot
but i'm going to take the over here i'm
not going to choose a side
not choosing a side i'm going to just
take the over everybody scores we all
hit
let's get rich
but let's see what these comments is
talking about because i want to see what
they are talking about and i'm giving
away the shorts i got moneyline killer
in the comments saying jazz first half
shout out to you moneyline killer you're
walking away with a hoodie i got rails
rails
in my bag says jazz spread as well shout
out to you okay i got sam joseph's
giannis is going to surpass kareem
kareem's buck scoring tonight and
solidified the bucks as the team to beat
in the east
i like that because i need points i'm
going for i got the over so i need
points i love that take sam sam you are
walking away with the br betting
basketball shorts the exclusive br
betting basketball shirts that i don't
have and i'm a little salty about that
sam richmond i'm a little
different sam is going to get that
before me
i can't believe a different sam was
getting that one before you two sam but
we talked major markets now let's talk
player props it's time for lock or not
i'm gonna put up a prop and i need all
of you to get in the comments and tell
me whether it is a lot
or it's not let's get right to it sam
starting off
with donovan mitchell to score 25 or
more points tonight it's sitting at
minus 102. sam talk to me talk to the
people do you like this one or do you
not
so i want to say yes here like i said i
i do like the jazz tonight i think it's
a good right spot for donovan mitchell
and the whole team but my concern is and
again sorry to the city of los angeles
but i think your team stinks i think the
jazz blow them out tonight and i think
you might see donovan mitchell and the
rest of the jazz starters do what steph
curry and you know the warriors are
known for from the past few years of not
even having to play the fourth quarters
because they're up by so many points um
so that kind of scares me i think he has
a good game but i am worried about him
sitting down the stretch so i'll stay
away here
sam is staying away uh
but sam i want to i want to talk about
my man donovan mitchell because he was
he was talking some talk to the media
not too long ago you know they they
dropped the one against the clippers
where they were up big and the clippers
came back and then uh
donovan was chirping in the media a
little bit trying to wake up his team
and usually when guys talk the talk
they come out and walk the walk 25
points
we're talking donovan mitchell here sam
i think that i'm going to lock that one
in but i'm in the comments i am in the
comments giving away hoodies a eddie
says over shout out to you a eddie
you're walking away with hoodie uh beep
out says risky stay away from the
mitchell bed
i mean hey i'm giving i'm giving both of
you guys hoodies b-pal you're also
walking away with hoodie because uh just
making you think a little bit do we want
to stay away or do we want to take the
over i'm taking it sam stand away so hey
that's just what we're gonna do but
we're moving on to the next
guy that we have on the prop sheet we
got rudy gobert to have 14 plus rebounds
sitting at -102 sam
talk to me talk to the people do you
like this one or do you not
i do like this one um obviously go bear
one of the best rebounders in the league
um it's a big number but again
lakers really low in rebounding rate not
a very good rebounding team
i again not a great lineup from them
tonight i think they're gonna miss a lot
of shots what does that mean a lot of
opportunity for gobert to stuff the
statute with rebounds hopefully he can
do it quick hopefully he can get off hot
and doing the first three quarters so if
he does have to sit we've already hit
the number but uh but yeah i'll take him
to get 14.
sam i'm gonna tell you on this one for
one reason and one reason only you
mentioned the lakers team they're not
that good and they're gonna miss a lot
of shots i can see them missing a lot of
shots and rudy gobert he's a real good
rebounder so uh i'm tailing you on this
one but i want to see what the people
are saying
so i'm in the handy dandy iphone and i
see john lee 35 80 says playoff gorbert
he is going to do it uh
shout out to you you're walking away
with honey ianna jana is in the comments
says i think it's a lock shout out to
you yana you are also walking away with
a hoodie uh they are going off in the
comments on the go bird rebounds the
comments is literally jumping uh but
let's move on sam because finally
we're talking about the man russell
westbrook to have six assists tonight
and it's plus
money
talk to me talk to the people do you
like this one sam or do you not
i do you might have expected me to go
the other way because i've done nothing
but slander the lakers here but i think
it's important to note like
who is gonna
have
the ball in their hands tonight if it's
not russell westbrook you obviously
lebron's out a.d is out the ball is
going to be in his hands it might be it
might take a while to get there because
again the lakers are probably going to
miss a lot of shots but i think
westbrook controls the game for the
lakers on the offensive end i think he's
going to have a lot of opportunities for
assists and i six is not that high of a
number especially when you look at
westbrook's career assist number so the
plus 110 i'm taking it
yes sam i want everybody everybody just
take a deep breath take a deep breath
and let's think about who this man
russell westbrook i understand this year
that he's having but let's not
disrespect
this man russell westbrook he is still
russell westbrook he is still i i
guarantee you if he wasn't on the lakers
if he was on a
non-competing team or a non-uh contender
team he will go out there and put and
put up a triple-double night in the
night out i have no doubt russell
westbrook can do that on a night in
night out basis but we're talking about
six assists and it's plus money here sam
it's russell westbrook no brawn he's
gonna have the ball in his hands a lot
of the most majority of the game for the
lakers i'm taking this i'm taking the
over give me
the six assists for my man russ give me
the plus money uh let me see what
they're talking about in the comments
though they might be all on oh rich
martel saying catch that
but i'm not giving you a hoodie rich
because he's spamming our comments you
cannot spam the comments in order to get
a hoodie just comment once or twice i
promise you i will see you uh i also see
juice maul drew small says that's easy
lock that in yes i do think that that
one's is easy mike bollins in the
comments saying big knife from russ mike
bolan we might see a big night from russ
and last but not least gabriel donna
says cash in rush with a bunch of locks
so uh
we're gonna we're gonna ride that one
we're gonna ride that one
but it's time to build the br betting
custom same game parlay sam
which you yes you at home can ride along
with us on fanduel tonight we're looking
at this next bucks game and i need
everybody and i mean everybody to get in
the comments and tell me what they think
which legs are locks which legs are not
sam are you ready bro cause i'm ready to
get right to it
let's do it man
we're getting right to it we're starting
it off i call him slim
you might call him kd but he's known as
kevin durant
to score 30 plus points tonight sam do
you think my man slim can get it done
i do man this is this is or this is kd
season i mean playoffs are coming up
best scorer in the league 30 points and
a national tv game uh with all eyes on
them so i love it yeah let's do it
sam earlier in the show i said i was
going to take the over in this game so
look how we are connecting the dots
follow me here sam we got 30 from kd can
we get 30 from giannis tonight
i like it i mean again he this is the
time i i agree with your overtake i do
think there's going to be a lot of
points tonight and i think against shows
up in these games you know the uh sixers
bucks game from a few days ago i scored
40 points he went off he was the best
guy in the court uh i think he goes off
again tonight i wouldn't be surprised if
hit 35 40 again so i'm with it
now sam i usually have a rule on the
show but i'm going to break it today i'm
i'm telling everybody i'm going to break
my rule my rule is usually
i'm not betting nobody other than
wardell stephen curry for more than
three three-pointers made in the game
but tonight
tonight sam i'm going to change that and
first up we got
kyrie irving three three pointers made i
feel really good about this one because
once again i need the ogre but sam do
you feel good about this one
yeah i'm we're aligned greg and that's
always a good sign i think there's going
to be a ton of points tonight i think
again season wrapping up stars are going
to show out in a nationally televised
game uh i think kyrie has a really nice
night and three threes for kyrie it's
not too many so let's do it
three for kyrie's not too many
but let's talk about
i would say he is the best player in the
league
when healthy
no doubt kevin durant is the best player
in the league win healthy i'll go on
record to say that
but can he get three threes tonight we
got the 30 points on this same game
parlay
can he go knock down three threes
tonight sam
he's got to get those 30 points somehow
so three threes again he you don't want
to bet against kevin durant scoring
point
you never want to put
yourself in that position so i i think
kd can knock down three threes
i think kd can knock down three threes
as well uh let's put the ticket up
because i want to show you guys if you
guys were go put a hundred dollars down
on our parlay
you guys will be walking around with 542
dollars and five cents
speaking of kevin durant we partner with
our friends over at fanduel for a
special boost for tonight fanduel is
offering a super boost for kevin durant
to score 30 plus points and the nets to
win boosted from plus 190 to plus 250.
make sure you get on fanduel for all the
details
sam are you rocking with this odds
boost by our
our by our friends over there at uh
fandor
yeah i mean i'm i'm staying away i'm
just gonna watch this game as a fan but
uh if i did have to pick a side it would
be the nets i think they need this game
a little bit more trying to stay in that
top eight seed for the play-in
tournament um they're right on the cusp
right now i think this game matters a
little bit more to them um so i i think
they'll want it more and i yeah we
already talked about it kd not betting
against that guy going for 30 on a
nationally televised game so uh so let's
do it
sam is rocking all right before i get in
the comments let's get back to this
parlay
what are you grading the parlay today
sam
i gotta go with a for the vibes you
don't you're not gonna give a bet that
you know we're taking is like a great
you gotta go and expect you're gonna win
so eight plus put good vibes in the air
sam's putting the good vibes in the air
i'm putting the i'm sending good vibes
to you by giving out more hoodies and
i'm also giving out a jersey i got a b
pals in the comments says middleton plus
three threes tonight he's like that one
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie uh i got dred flock says
pat cunnington big sleeper tonight
middleton's gonna have three plus threes
tonight as well shout out to you
dreadflock you are walking away with a
hoodie this next one i'm giving away
the jersey uh i got calvin j hearn 23
says given this parlay a plus kd and
giannis scored 30 in their sleep they're
both averaging 30. they will go at each
other kyrie will make up for his
struggles in his home debut so he will
bring it tonight against the team that
took them out and drain over three
threes katie will also drain multiple
threes easy money shout out to you jay
hearn appreciate the good vibes
appreciate the good vibes you are
walking away with a jersey of your
choice
sam you've been talking about them
you've been talking about them so let's
let's talk a little bit more about them
at the beginning of the season the
lakers were minus 5 000 to make the
playoffs
now they could potentially not make it
at all do you think they are out for the
count or do you think they can still
sneak in there
i think they could sneak in but i would
bet against it look yeah so i think
they're plus 165 to make the play in
right now uh i'm staying away from it i
think this team just is is not very good
um they're going to lose tonight i know
uh a.d is supposed to return tomorrow
lebron is supposed to return tomorrow
but are those guys even fully healthy
and even if they are the rest of the
team just isn't very good and i think
the most important thing with them is
their schedule down the stretch is
really really hard they're playing teams
like the nuggets the
sons i think they have to go to oracle
like they have a really tough schedule
whereas
again i think some of the other teams
they're competing with from the play and
have a lot easier path to making it and
the spurs on the tie breaker over them
so i actually think the lakers are gonna
miss the plan
sam has spoken he said he thinks the
lakers is gonna miss the play-in but
today we asked you all on the app if you
guys think the lakers have a chance to
still make the postseason
but i need everybody that is right here
right now to get in the comments and
tell me if you guys think it is possible
that the lakers can make the postseason
let's take a look at the current odds
there they are sam
um
you see the san antonio spurs there sea
of minnesota
see new orleans those are
the value i just want to talk value here
sam do you see any value
right here
on this on this this graphic on who's
going to make the playing tournament
yeah so i think pelicans definitely will
p wolves obviously will but again the
the odds are are priced in there i think
the spurs do get that last
uh
ins 270 it it's tough um because again
lebron and adr are coming back but i do
think they make it they have the tie
breaker they have a much easier path um
minus 270 is a lot but i do think they
get that 10th spot
sam said he's rocking with the spurs
but uh i'm going to hop in here hey
throw the dice at them lakers bronze
coming back 80s coming back
i could see them potentially
you know figuring out a way to at least
make the play in
but uh we'll we'll see we'll see it's
plus 165
i will i'll put my money on brian a year
in year out bronze been putting up
numbers and he's been doing things that
we haven't seen before so i put my money
on bron but let me get into these
comments let me get into these comments
and let me get into these uh comments so
i can give away some hoodies uh i see
yeehaw sports says hit a teamer last
night yeehaw shout out to you yeehaw
you're walking away with a hoodie for
hitting that a teamer uh here we go new
uh juice moss as new orleans pales
rolling with the home team they have
been playing great lately
okay he's he you see the pales getting
in uh one more one more gabriel done
says lakers lock
playoffs with tourney play
i think the same thing gabriel so both
of you guys everybody that i mentioned
you all are walking away with the hoodie
all right sam we talked about the
playoffs a little bit
let's move on to some mvp conversations
let's take a look at the current odds
there they are and uh
yokitch is up top at minus 165.
you see him beat you see anta takumpo
sam talk to me talk to the people
which way are you leaning brother
yeah so i'm very passionate about this
i'll try and not take up uh five minutes
here but i did bet jokic two days ago at
plus 160. i know he's now minus 160. so
the odds have moved a little bit but i
still do think there is value here i i
would put him around minus 200 minus
250. i think it's important with these
awards you can't think about it as like
who would i pick for mvp you really have
to it's about who the voters are going
to pick and i think we got a really good
tell about which way the voters were
leaning a few days ago espn's tim
bontemps basically reached out to the
actual voters for mvp and asked them who
he who they would take and pretty
overwhelmingly they said nikola jokic is
the mvp i think jokic out of a hundred
got like 62 first place votes and embiid
got around 28 so pretty huge gap there
um so i think about that i think embiid
has a lot of ground to make up in these
final two weeks of the season and i
honestly don't think he's doing it i
think if anything it's going the other
way since that uh voting took place
jokic has gone for a triple double he
went for like 37 14 and 9 yesterday but
i think even more importantly is that
embiid and the sixers probably their
last marquee game of the season against
giannis and the bucks got out played by
giannis yana scored 40 points and embiid
was blocked on the last play of the game
by giannis and the sixers lost the game
so i think if anything there was
probably a decent gap obviously by the
voting a few days ago
who was the favorite and i think if
anything it's probably widened so i
think the value is slowly creeping away
but i think it's still there so i i
would recommend taking yoka triton out
around minus 160 minus 165.
sam is rocking with
uh
hey i like it b man i i feel like james
harden kind of when he came you know it
kind of took and beats thunder he was
putting up crazy numbers in january
february he's putting up crazy numbers
james harden came over and then
you know
kind of mellowed out but uh who knows i
always say about the mvp race it's a run
away and
maybe envy can go on the run again who
knows
but
you know what i
it's time to give out some more hoodies
sam i'm in the giving spirit so i need
everybody to get in the comments and
give me your takes on who you think is
going to win mvp
uh
i'm in the i'm i'm in the comments right
now i'm i'm in the comments and i see m
kent unfortunately
uh
he's
m king you're m kent you're walking away
with a hoodie i lost his comment sam the
comments are jumping michael mono jokic
winning back-to-back mvp is definitely
worse than nash mvps wow i i i guess so
but shout out to you michael you're
walking away
with a hoodie uh mgo blue is in the
comments
m emgo blue is in the comments saying
katie for mvp the time that he missed
shouldn't hurt his mvp chances it shows
how valuable he actually is i don't see
that actually happening but uh i i mean
i i like i i i like the comment because
kd i do think kd is one of the best
players but it doesn't matter mvp
doesn't matter who's the best player it
matters how valuable that player is to
their team in that particular season and
katie missed way too many games for me
to say that he's mvp this year but uh
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
shout out to everybody that i uh just
mentioned you guys are walking away with
hoodies sam
let's get up out of here bro thank you
to everybody
for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today the 3x2 is a lock
the br betting same game parlay is a
lock sam gave it an a as its grade we'll
be back next thursday giving out more
hoodies more jerseys and more locks if
you want a hoodie we will dm you
alongside the man the myth the legend
sam richmond i'm greg ivory we are
leaving the group chat
[Music]
you